Nous allons reprendre ces études sur la création,
donc c'est le quatrième chapitre de la confession de foi.
Donc nous pouvons relire les paragraphes 2 et 3,
donc si certains ont la confession de foi avec vous.
Les paragraphes 2 et 3, bientôt on va lire ensemble.
Mais les premiers paragraphes, ils traitent de la création de l'univers
et c'est intéressant de considérer la manière progressive
dont on doit toujours migrer du plus général envers les plus spécifiques.
C'est comme ça que Dieu a créé toutes les choses,
l'être humain étant créé l'image des dieux comme quelque chose de spécial,
mais en commençant par la création de tout l'univers.
Donc là on a pris du temps et on a mis beaucoup d'emphase
sur l'importance de reconnaître que l'interprétation littérale des jeunesses
est une question confessionnelle, est une question historique,
c'est-à-dire que par rapport à presque 2000 ans d'histoire d'église
et même plus avec toute l'histoire d'Israël,
Genèse a toujours été interprétée de manière littérale.
Genèse signifie histoire et c'est comme ça que la Bible elle-même,
quand on arrive en Exode chapitre 20,
Dieu lui-même va interpréter Genèse en disant
« En six jours, Dieu a créé toutes les choses ».
Et donc là c'est important pour nous de nous rappeler de cette réalité.
Si ce n'était pas la pression de certaines théories qui ont été vendues
et popularisées comme en étant des découvertes scientifiques,
lorsqu'elles n'étaient pas sequer des théories,
on ne serait pas sous cette pression et la génération plus récente
d'églises et des chrétiens, des théologiens,
ne serait pas corrompue à cet égard, à l'égard de l'interprétation biblique.
Par contre, c'est une question confessionnelle.
Selon l'enseignement intrabiblique et selon l'enseignement historique,
l'interprétation de Genèse est littérale.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'il nous apprend à propos de l'interprétation de la création
à partir du récit de Genèse ?
C'est que Dieu a créé tout l'univers,
fiat et ex-ninu,
c'est-à-dire qu'il a créé toutes les choses par sa parole,
par son décret.
Et ex-nirilu, à partir d'aucun matériel qui était préexistant,
à partir de rien, à partir de sa parole et de soi-même.
Et on a considéré tout ce qui cela implique au niveau âge de la création, par exemple,
et au niveau doctrinaire aussi,
par rapport à la connexion historique entre Genèse et même les plans de la rédemption.
Donc ensuite, on a considéré la création spéciale de l'homme,
en ayant d'abord considéré la création de tout l'univers.
Donc, au sixième jour, on considère qu'il y a un mouvement apothéotique
envers la création de l'homme.
Dieu s'arrête.
Il y a une conférence intratrinitaire.
On contemple les pluriel, faisons pluriel, l'homme notre image,
à notre ressemblance.
Et à partir de là, on a considéré combien spéciale est la création de l'homme,
selon les récits bibliques.
Dans ce qui concerne ce qu'il y a de spécial dans la création de l'homme,
on a considéré aussi quelle est la constitution de l'homme.
Et là, on a parlé, l'homme est un être intégral,
mais il est composé d'au moins deux dimensions inséparables,
sa portion matérielle, sa portion immatérielle,
en ayant toujours un impact l'une sur l'autre.
Mais dans sa portion immatérielle,
nous devons reconnaître qu'il y a cette notion des synonymes entre esprit et âme,
et en même temps, la Bible nous pointe quelques distinctions,
sans vouloir faire une séparation complète entre les deux,
entre l'âme et l'esprit,
l'esprit étant surtout ce qui nous unissait à Dieu avant la chute,
et l'homme, il est mort spirituel,
et voilà pourquoi on est livré au péché de l'âme parfois,
au péché du corps parfois,
et donc il y a cette distinction.
Donc, on a considéré la constitution de l'homme en tant qu'image de Dieu,
et on a commencé à considérer ce qu'il y a de plus important dans l'homme,
et donc c'est un thème très mystérieux,
c'est un thème qui n'a pas toujours de l'unanimité,
mais pour ce qui est le plus important,
nous trouvons toujours de l'unanimité dans la considération des théologiens,
c'est-à-dire, on sait très bien,
Dieu est infini dans ses vertus, dans ses qualités,
nous savons que nous ne serons jamais Dieu nous-mêmes,
et nous savons que Dieu n'a pas de corps, par exemple,
Dieu n'est pas visible, par exemple,
mais nous savons que Dieu nous a créés tels que nous sommes,
y compris les corps, comme image de Dieu.
Et donc, par là, on fait beaucoup d'exercices pour essayer de comprendre,
et c'est pour ça qu'on a dû, avant de considérer,
voilà, l'image de Dieu de manière plus positive,
de prendre le temps de considérer quelques points importants
pour savoir comment arriver à la compréhension de l'image de Dieu.
La pertinence, elle est très importante pour nous,
il y a toujours l'impact entre l'interprétation littérale des Genèses
et l'état des choses aujourd'hui,
l'état des choses aujourd'hui dans la société, dans l'Église,
car, voilà, l'exemple qu'on a donné,
c'est, par exemple, des femmes pasteurs dans nos jours.
Et il y a jusque-là un impact entre les respects dans Genèse littérale,
qui nous enseigne à propos de la complémentarité des genres
et comment cela devrait s'étendre dans toute la société,
dans toutes les esphères,
et à partir du moment où on se permet d'être très flexible
dans l'abordage littéral de Genèse,
on aura tous ces types d'impacts dans toutes les aires de la vie.
Donc, je donne juste cet exemple,
mais la réalité aujourd'hui de l'homme qui ne se connaît pas
et l'homme qui définit l'anthropologie comme une science humaine,
c'est-à-dire non exacte,
et on sait très bien que c'est une science non exacte
pour les êtres humains susceptibles de leur propre observation,
de leur propre pensée.
La psychanalyse, la philosophie, la sociologie
qui seront toujours passibles des beaucoup d'erreurs,
car ils partent aujourd'hui d'un présupposé radicalement opposé
au récit biblique.
Donc, pour la Bible,
on n'est pas en train d'évoluer à partir d'une genèse,
d'une énergie qui explose,
qui n'a pas dépensé des sentiments,
qui ne peut pas justifier l'homme tel qu'il est
dans ces crises existentielles,
dans sa demande d'avoir un sens, une signification,
être un être qui a des demandes,
des relations, d'amour.
Comment pouvons-nous aujourd'hui protéger la dignité
de l'être humain,
si l'être humain n'est qu'il est fruit d'une explosion ?
Et donc, toutes ces crises qui vont avoir beaucoup d'impact dans la société
ont pour racines,
et toutes les méthodes pour chercher à régler les problèmes de l'homme
sont des méthodes qui ne sont pas fondées sur la base
d'une anthropologie exacte.
Si Dieu est le créateur de l'être humain,
c'est Dieu qui va nous enseigner qui nous sommes,
comment nous fonctionnons,
quel est notre problème,
comment les régler,
et voilà pourquoi,
si on était plus connaisseur de ce qui nous sommes
selon la définition biblique,
et moins donner l'écoute à ce qui nous sommes
selon la compréhension psychanalytique,
selon la compréhension de la sociologie,
etc.,
on serait beaucoup plus en mesure de nous soigner
tel que la Bible nous propose de nous soigner.
D'ailleurs, les termes psychés viennent de la Bible,
c'est l'âme,
et Dieu, Christ,
et les médecins de l'âme.
Et donc là, c'est important pour nous,
ce n'est pas pour rejeter toutes les découvertes,
car nous trouverons par la grâce commune
beaucoup d'intercessions envers l'enseignement biblique,
et des enseignements qu'on peut trouver dans la société,
mais c'est très important pour nous d'être conscients
que la base est profondément contrastante, opposée,
et nous devons être dans une attitude de filtre
et surtout consacrer le maximum de notre attention
à ce que la parole nous enseigne à propos de l'anthropologie.
L'anthropologie, c'est-à-dire l'étude à propos de l'homme
selon la Bible, est inhérent.
C'est le récit du Créateur.
Et donc nous devons surtout chercher à comprendre
quel est le but de notre existence,
qu'est-ce qui peut vraiment satisfaire nos demandes
les plus fondamentales, les plus existentielles.
Elles sont toutes liées à comprendre ce qui nous sommes,
pourquoi Dieu nous a créés à l'origine,
et la manière de régler aussi nos crises.
Donc les considérations générales,
je vais revenir sur quelques-unes,
car elles sont très importantes
pour qu'on continue à étudier l'image des dieux.
Donc comment définir l'image des dieux dans l'homme
en reconnaissant qu'il s'est mystérieux
et en ayant considéré la pertinence non seulement par rapport à notre existence aujourd'hui,
mais aussi sa pertinence par rapport à la Bible,
la relation entre les doctrines.
Jésus nous est présenté comme le deuxième Adam.
Dans les langages bibliques de la conversion
et de la sanctification,
de la restauration de ce qui nous sommes,
qui comprend aussi notre joie,
la sanctification,
elle est considérée comme être refait à l'image des dieux en Christ.
Donc les langages de l'image des dieux,
de ce qui l'homme est dans son essence,
il va impréguer toutes les écritures,
il y aura toujours un impact entre les doctrines.
Et donc, la première chose qu'on a considérée,
c'est la notion d'image et ressemblance,
cette notion des miroirs ou des projections.
Images ayant une racine
qui signifie plutôt esculptée ou taillée,
évoquent l'idée d'une forme, d'une structure ou d'une représentation.
Donc dans les mondes anciens,
les rois faisaient des sculptures
pour représenter sa domination,
pour représenter son autorité.
Donc quelque part, Dieu nous a créés
pour être une copie,
une copie qui avait un but aussi
de représenter sa présence dans les mondes,
sa règle dans les mondes.
Et l'autre mot, pour parler des ressemblables,
signifie d'être semblables,
des rassemblés ou des ressemblés, pardon,
et donc suggère une similitude,
mais une similitude qui est aussi relationnelle et fonctionnelle.
Et donc c'est clair que nous ne sommes pas une copie parfaite de Dieu,
dans le sens où nous sommes analogues à Dieu.
On était à l'origine une copie parfaite,
mais on n'était pas Dieu.
On n'avait pas les capacités
qui nous avons en similarité aux capacités de Dieu,
qui nous distinguent de tous les autres êtres créés,
mais qui en même temps ne seront pas dans les mêmes dégrés
que Dieu les a.
Et donc par exemple, la moralité, la raisonnabilité,
nous avons ces choses de manière similaire à Dieu,
mais de manière limitée par rapport à l'infini qui est Dieu là.
Donc l'illustration qui nous aide pour l'ensemble des leçons,
c'est d'imaginer véritablement ces trois dimensions
qu'on peut observer dans les reflets d'une image dans un miroir.
Donc la première chose à retenir,
c'est que Dieu nous a créés pour vivre devant lui.
Il n'y a pas une image qui puisse refléter un objet qui ne soit pas là.
Vous êtes avec moi.
Donc nous ne pouvons que refléter Dieu,
car Dieu nous a créés avant tout
pour réjouir de cette relation privilégiée avec lui,
par la contemplation de Dieu,
par la vie corandéau, devant la face de Dieu.
On est son image.
Et on est son image dans un premier moment,
tout simplement parce que nous sommes.
Donc nous sommes, nous avons été créés à l'image de Dieu.
Mais nous avons reçu aussi des capacités similaires aux capacités des dieux.
La capacité de recréer, la capacité de raisonner,
la capacité de ressentir, on va voir après,
de manière plus spécifique.
Mais la réalité, c'est que même si Dieu, on va dire,
ne bouge pas et nous sommes son reflet dans un miroir,
il a la capacité de commencer à bouger,
d'avoir quelques attributs.
Et lorsque Dieu commence à agir,
nous devons aussi agir tel que Dieu agit.
Donc Dieu nous a créés pour être son représentant,
pour agir tel que Dieu agit.
Et donc nous sommes image de Dieu.
Nous avons des capacités
qui nous avons reçues,
qui se rapportent aux capacités des dieux.
Et nous devons agir.
Et donc c'est une question d'être,
mais c'est une question aussi
des relations et des privilèges.
Mais c'est aussi une question de rédivabilité
et d'obligation d'être l'image des dieux.
Et donc, les termes sont utilisés avant et après la chute.
Et donc, même s'il a été profondément corrompu,
il continue.
Et donc, c'est pour ça que c'est difficile de savoir
où dans la Bible chercher à comprendre
l'image des dieux dans l'homme.
Car même après la chute,
il y a quelque chose qui reste en nous.
Elle n'est pas limitée à la création.
Et comme je vous ai dit,
je pense que ça c'est très important.
Certains théologiens proposent
que les lieux parfaits pour considérer
l'image des dieux pour l'homme
étaient quelque chose que Dieu prévoyait
depuis avant même la fondation du monde,
c'est-à-dire l'envoi du Christ incarné.
Et donc, par là,
certains trouvent la base
de dire que notre corps a été créé
à l'image du Christ incarné,
ressuscité, glorifié,
tel qu'il sera effectivement dans le futur.
Mais indépendamment du lieu exact
où nous allons placer,
c'est très important de nous concentrer
d'abord dans la création.
Et cela n'est pas la seule base
pour justifier les corps
comme image des dieux aussi,
comme étant aussi une dimension
d'image des dieux.
Car dans ce monde visible,
pour agir et fonctionner
en tant qu'image des dieux
reconnaissable,
nous avons besoin de ces véhicules
qui ont été parfaitement créés par Dieu,
adaptés à nous permettre
de fonctionner comme image des dieux.
Nous devons nous rappeler toujours
que si nous sommes l'image des dieux
et même l'image du Christ,
nous ne sommes pas Dieu ni Christ
et les Christ incarnés,
ils restent quand même
d'un ordre infiniment supérieur
à tout autre être humain.
Donc lui, il est l'empreinte
de la personne des dieux,
il est le reflet lui-même
de la gloire des dieux.
Nous sommes des ombres
ou des projections,
même si dans notre condition originale
est parfaite.
Et donc, il y a la distinction
entre l'image naturelle
et l'image spirituelle,
parfois on dit ça.
Donc il y a l'homme dans sa nature,
dans son ensemble,
il est image des dieux
et par là, on pense à la raisonnabilité,
l'autoconscience,
la capacité de prendre décision,
l'aspect relationnel,
mais il y a aussi cette notion spirituelle
qui nous rapporte avant tout
et surtout à Dieu
qui devrait être les noyaux
et la source de toutes
les autres manifestations
de l'image des dieux en nous.
Il y a aussi la distinction
entre l'image des dieux étroite
ou plus large.
Et là, on fait la distinction
entre l'état original
des justices parfaites,
des saintétés parfaites,
d'Éphésiens 4, 23,
où la Bible nous rappelle
que nous sommes renouvelés
dans l'esprit de notre intelligence,
à nous revêtir de l'homme nouveau,
créé selon Dieu dans la justice,
sainteté,
qui produit la vérité.
Et ça nous rappelle
que nous avons été créés à l'origine
avec ces trois offices
pour nous rapporter
toutes les relations dans l'univers
en tant que prophète,
c'est-à-dire liés à la vérité des dieux,
la capacité d'Adam à l'origine,
par exemple,
de nommer les animaux,
de reconnaître la vérité des dieux
et la responsabilité,
on va dire,
d'organiser les mondes,
surtout par la parole.
C'est comme ça qu'on va
récréer les œuvres des dieux,
mais surtout par cette connaissance
de la vérité
et l'organisation de la réalité
selon la vérité des dieux.
Et donc,
cet aspect d'être toujours un prophète,
et nous,
dans toutes nos relations,
nous avons cette responsabilité
et rédébabilité,
être image des dieux
pour marcher dans la direction
de la parole des dieux
et pour produire la parole des dieux.
La même chose par rapport
à cette sainteté
qui fait référence
à la notion royale,
quelque part,
car on est un royaume sans
et donc c'est cette notion
de chercher,
de gouverner nos vies
par la sainteté des dieux
et promouvoir la sainteté des dieux.
Et donc,
nous avons cette responsabilité aussi
dans tous les domaines
d'agir de cette manière.
Et la justice
qui nous renvoie aussi
à la notion des prêtres,
d'être juste
pour pouvoir accéder
à la présence des dieux
et zéler pour la justice
à cet égard.
Donc,
ces trois offices
nous parlent plus
de ce qu'on appelle
la structure
des lettres humains
ou l'image des dieux
dans son sens plus étroits
et la notion
des fonctions aussi,
les sens plus larges
de l'image des dieux.
Et donc,
c'est comme si
la source essentielle
de l'image des dieux
est l'âme,
les sièges particuliers
et ses rayons
vont se manifester
dans toutes les ères
de nos vies
de cette manière.
Et donc,
il y a cette discussion aussi
entre structure
et fonction.
Est-ce qu'il est
ou non ?
Il porte tout simplement
l'image des dieux
et il fonctionne
tout simplement
comme l'image des dieux
ou est-ce qu'il est
dans son structure
l'image des dieux ?
Et la réalité,
c'est que la réponse,
c'est les deux choses
sont vraies.
Quand on va vers les schémas,
par exemple,
écoute,
oh Israël,
les seigneurs,
ton dieu
est le seul vrai dieu,
tu dois l'aimer
de tout ton cœur,
c'est-à-dire
de toute ton âme,
de toute ton intelligence
et de toutes tes forces.
Et donc,
c'est-à-dire que
si être image des dieux
signifie
de prendre plaisir en lui,
de l'aimer
et communiquer
ce fait
que notre dieu
est totalement aimable
par la manière
dont on vit,
on manifeste
cet amour,
cette adoration à dieu
et cette amabilité
de dieu
dans notre relation
intime avec lui,
dans nos affections
vers lui,
dans notre connaissance
de lui
et en les faisant connaissables,
mais aussi par nos forces.
Donc,
les trois dimensions
de l'être humain
sont engagées
et la réalité,
c'est que nous ne sommes pas
qu'image des dieux,
nous fonctionnons aussi
comme image des dieux,
nous sommes privilégiés
et responsables
et quand Dieu a créé l'homme,
ces deux aspects
sont clairement présents.
Donc,
puis Dieu dit
faisons l'homme
notre image
selon notre rassemblance
et qu'il domine
sur les poissons
de la mer,
etc.
Donc,
il va fonctionner
comme image des dieux,
dominer sur les poissons,
etc.
ayant été créé
dans son être
en tant qu'image
et ressemblance des dieux.
Dieu créa l'homme
à son image,
il est créé
à l'image des dieux,
il créa l'homme
et la femme.
Ok ?
Et donc,
sortant du cadre
de la structure
et fonction,
donc on dit
il est intégralement,
donc on n'a même pas besoin
de faire cette distinction,
mais même s'il est
inséparable,
un être
avec des capacités
pour être image des dieux
et qui doit fonctionner
comme image des dieux,
c'est important pour nous
d'identifier
quels sont les aspects.
Et donc,
juste pour vous donner
un rappel,
ce sont
toutes les choses
qui nous font rassembler
à Dieu
en nous distinguant
surtout
de tous les êtres créés
à part l'être humain
et qui vont avoir
directement
un rapport
avec les attributs
des dieux.
Par exemple,
quand on parle
de l'être humain
en tant qu'image
des dieux,
on parle
de son invisibilité
car même si
nous avons un corps,
nous avons
et nous savons
que la réalité
de notre existence
invisible
est plus réelle
quelque part,
même s'il y a
temporairement
la séparation
entre les corps
et l'âme,
l'âme continue,
donc nous sommes
conscients
d'avoir cette portion
invisible
au sein de nous-mêmes
qui est directement
liée
à l'aspect
spirituel
invisible
des dieux.
L'immortalité,
même si Dieu
est éternel,
n'a pas un point
de départ
et il existera
pour toujours.
Nous,
on a eu un point
de départ
mais on a été créé
avec cette
immortalité
dérivée
des dieux
qui est aussi
son image
dans notre être.
Ensuite,
quand on considère
les capacités
ou les attributs,
nos facultés
psychologiques
comme la rationalité,
la moralité,
la conscience,
la complexité
émotionnelle,
la volonté,
la notion
d'être
autoconscient,
c'est-à-dire
conscient de nous-mêmes,
la capacité
de réfléchir,
de méditer,
de juger,
d'analyser
la complexité
des langages,
l'aspect
relationnel,
donc tout cela
fait partie
de la personnalité
de l'homme
qui est à l'image
de notre Dieu
personnel
comme on a étudié
sur les attributs
des dieux.
Donc l'homme,
il a non seulement
plus de capacités
à ses égards,
infiniment plus
vis-à-vis
à certains animaux
qui peuvent être
parfois intelligents,
mais il a
quelques-unes
de ses attributs,
quelques-uns
de ses attributs
qui ne sont
trouvés
dans aucun autre
cas,
animal
qu'on trouve
dans la création.
La conscience
spirituelle,
donc les phénomènes
religieux
qu'il y a
l'être humain,
l'intégrité
morale
et intellectuelle
originaire,
donc comme on a vu
en Ephésiens,
la justice,
la vérité,
la sainteté,
même si
elles ont été
corrompues
et radicalement
après la chute,
ça reste
chez tous les
êtres humains
encore la capacité
de raisonner.
Nous ne sommes plus
sans,
mais nous sommes
et nous ressentons
la coupabilité.
donc Paul va dire
que ça reste
dans la,
les empreintes
des dieux
dans la conscience
des empies
qui procèdent
parfois
en conformité
avec la voie des dieux.
Ils démontrent
qu'ils ont la voie des dieux
qui n'est pas
complètement effacée
dans leur cœur.
Et donc là,
on voit
d'une manière très claire
que cette notion
des saintétés,
des piétés,
des divinités,
donc l'athéisme
selon l'apôtre Paul
n'est pas une réalité.
C'est un mensonge.
Personne
ne sera excusé
pour dire
mais moi j'étais athée,
j'avais pas la connaissance
des dieux
car les empreintes
sont dans leur propre
conscience
et dans leur environnement.
Il n'y a personne
qui soit véritablement athée.
De se déclarer athée,
c'est une décision
d'aller contrairement
à toute évidence
et chercher à supprimer
Dieu
et l'évidence des dieux
dans leur cœur.
L'être humain,
il est l'image des dieux.
C'est-à-dire
les faits
qu'ils nous soyons,
qu'ils nous existons,
c'est déjà
une preuve évidente
et inexcusable
que Dieu existe
devant nous-mêmes.
Et donc là,
c'est la réalité de l'homme.
Et les corps,
soit par la considération
comme je vous ai dit
d'avoir été créé
à l'image du Christ
qui viendrait,
soit tout simplement
pour exercer cette fonction
et la réalité
c'est que les futurs
nous ont assuré,
Philippiens 3, 21,
nous serons ressuscités
à l'image
ou à la conformité
avec les Christs glorifiés.
Et donc,
un autre aspect important,
c'est de considérer
cet aspect relationnel
de l'être humain
qui est supérieur
à toute autre sorte
d'existence,
même si les relations
existent entre les animaux,
elles ne peuvent pas
être comparables
à la noblesse,
à la gloire
de cette relation
car,
comme Ephésiens 5 nous dit,
la relation
entre les êtres humains
était basée aussi
sur la relation
entre Christ et l'Église,
basée déjà
par sa pluralité
sur et ancrée
sur les dieux famille,
les dieux trinitaires
et donc,
on a été créé
en tant qu'être familieux
à l'image des dieux,
en tant qu'être relationnel
et Dieu va nous présenter
en tant qu'être
père de toute l'humanité
et particulièrement
de tous les racheter
ou adopter,
même si parfois
certains d'entre nous
ne développent pas
une famille biologique,
nous sommes tous partis
de la réalité spirituelle,
de la famille,
de la foi
et nous devons aussi
agir selon
ce que notre sexe particulier
représente,
agir comme homme,
agir comme père,
agir avec les responsabilités
qu'on a
au sein de la communauté,
bien sûr,
gardant les distances
et la proportion
qui soit spirituelle
et biblique,
mais les mêmes principes,
la maturité
et la sanctification
de l'homme
et de la femme
va se porter toujours
dans la direction
de mieux agir
en tant qu'image
de Dieu
comme homme
ou comme femme,
comme père
ou comme mère
et donc là,
nous voyons,
ou même comme enfant
aussi
et donc là,
c'est intéressant,
il y a cet aspect
relationnel
et la Bible
est très claire
par rapport
à la complémentarité
des genres
à cet égard.
Donc,
Dieu a créé
l'égalité
des valeurs
entre homme et femme,
image de Dieu,
homme et femme.
Par contre,
distinction
entre homme et femme
aussi
de manière très claire.
Dès là,
on a considéré
les mandats culturels,
les mandats sociaux
et les mandats spirituels.
Donc,
on n'a pas le temps
de revenir sur tout,
mais c'est juste
pour vous rappeler
que dans les contextes
de la création
de l'homme,
l'homme a été commissionné
à,
par exemple,
dominer la terre,
cultiver la terre,
bien sûr,
comme Dieu
a laissé les modèles
sur les jardins des dents.
Donc,
c'est pour développer,
elle sera à servir,
mais c'est pour développer
de la culture,
développer de la science même,
mais développer la terre
afin qu'elle puisse servir
au bien des êtres humains
et en faisant un usage
qui zèle pour les biens
des animaux
et de la terre elle-même.
OK ?
Ensuite,
tout comme Dieu l'a fait.
Et donc,
les mandats sociaux,
c'est bien sûr,
multipliez-vous,
remplissez la terre
et,
bien sûr,
compris par là,
développez les sociétés
sur la base
du noyau familial original.
Donc,
la famille précède la société.
L'État ne peut jamais
devenir plus grand
que la famille.
L'État ne doit jamais
avoir des droits
envers nos enfants.
OK ?
Qui surmontent
les droits
que les parents ont.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est cette harmonie,
cette suture,
l'homme qui fonctionne
comme homme,
la femme qui fonctionne
comme femme,
la famille qui fonctionne
comme la famille des dieux
avec ces principes
d'autorité et de soumission
que nous trouvons même
dans la suture
des œuvres trinitaires
et des titres trinitaires,
père, fils,
Saint-Esprit,
nous devrions apprendre
par là la richesse
et la gloire.
Personne n'osera dire
que la soumission du fils
au père est quelque chose
de mauvais.
La soumission,
elle est mauvaise
quand nous prenons
la corruption
et nous allons comprendre
comment ça a eu lieu.
Et donc,
les mandats spirituels,
qui sont les plus importants,
qui vont permettre
ou impréguer
tous les autres mandats.
Car lorsque j'essaierai
en train de me rapporter
à la terre
pour faire que la terre
me sert et sert
les autres,
lorsque je ferai
un usage d'un animal,
je dois les faire
sachant que je les fais
devant la face des dieux.
Donc,
mon intégrité
à mon travail,
dans mes relations,
qui ne sont pas réduites
à la famille,
mais dans la société,
elle sera toujours vécue
devant la face des dieux.
Donc,
les samedis,
les derniers jours
de la semaine,
étaient les jours
où,
après avoir vécu
les privilèges
de travailler,
de cultiver,
de réjouir
des relations familiales,
de devoir fonctionner
comme sacerdo,
prophète
et roi,
quelque part,
au sein de ma famille.
Les samedis,
c'est les jours
de la célébration
pour remercier Dieu
du privilège
de pouvoir avoir
représenté,
reproduit sa vie
pendant cette semaine,
mais c'est aussi
les jours
de la rédivabilité.
C'est aussi les jours
où Dieu va nous demander
les comptes
que nous devons rendre
par rapport à la manière
comment cette semaine,
on a pu représenter Dieu
dans nos relations.
En tant que mère,
en tant que père,
en tant que travailleur
dans la société,
est-ce que j'ai fonctionné
comment un homme doit fonctionner,
comment une femme
doit fonctionner
dans les relations particulières
appropriées aux hommes
ou aux femmes.
Et donc,
c'est très important pour nous
de nous rappeler
les mandats spirituels.
Donc,
c'est cette adoration,
l'obligation
d'adorer Dieu,
quelque part.
Donc,
c'est les commandements
les plus favorables
à l'être humain,
car Dieu est le seul
capable de supporter
la vraie adoration.
Il est le seul
capable de donner
du sens
au mot adoration.
Il est le seul
capable de remplir
et de satisfaire
les demandes
d'adoration
que l'être humain
a.
Donc,
lorsque Dieu nous ordonne
de l'adorer,
c'est car s'il ne nous ordonne
pas de l'adorer,
il est en train
de sponsoriser
l'idolâtrie.
Si nous adorons
n'importe quelle chose,
n'importe qui
plus qu'est Dieu,
c'est faux,
c'est injuste,
c'est des idolâtries.
Et la réalité,
c'est qu'il ne peut pas
faire partie
de ces mensonges.
Il nous a créés
pour satisfaire nos âmes
dans la seule chose
qui a la capacité
de les faire,
c'est sa gloire infinie.
Et voilà pourquoi
les mandats spirituels,
c'est les mandats
de pointer envers Dieu
et réjouir Dieu
par tout ce qu'on fait
et de manière directe
par cette relation.
Donc,
les quatre états
de l'image de Dieu
pour conclure cette étude
sont l'image de Dieu
à l'origine.
Les premiers,
donc l'homme a été créé
l'image de Dieu
dans une relation parfaite
avec Dieu,
avec ses semblables
et avec la création,
sans aucun péché.
OK ?
Voici les trois relations,
les trois mandats principaux.
Faisons l'homme
à notre image
selon notre assemblance
et Dieu créa l'homme
à son image,
il est créé à l'image de Dieu,
il est créé à homme et femme.
Verset 31,
Dieu vit tout ce qu'il avait fait
et voici cela était très bon.
D'ailleurs,
c'est un argument
assez important aussi
pour considérer
la possibilité
que la chute
de Satan
a eu lieu
après la création
de l'homme.
Car ici,
c'est la conclusion
de toutes les œuvres
de Dieu
et tout était très bon.
Genèse 2, 18,
l'éternel Dieu dit
« Il n'est pas bon
que l'homme soit seul ».
Donc ici,
c'est intéressant
la manière dont Dieu
va conduire l'homme
lui-même
à constater cette réalité.
C'est une déclaration
qui vaut jusqu'aujourd'hui
et qui va valoir
pour toujours.
l'être humain
n'est pas bon
qu'il soit seul.
Et là,
dans ce cas-là,
bien sûr,
c'est la liaison directe
envers la femme
mais nous savons
que les Christ
n'étaient pas mariés
biologiquement
ni l'apôtre Paul
et ce sont
deux des personnes
les plus joyeuses
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Mais c'est clair
que sauf si Dieu
nous donne un appel
extraordinaire,
rare,
pour vivre les célibats,
il faut présupposer
plutôt
que nous n'avons pas
cet appel.
OK ?
Et il faut chercher
comme l'une
des plus grandes
objectifs
et des plus grandes
demandes naturelles
qu'on a dans notre vie
de nous marier,
de maturer
envers les mariages.
Donc,
il n'est pas bon
qu'il y ait
l'homme soit seul.
Dieu le savait déjà
dès le début
mais il a voulu aussi
qu'il y ait
l'homme
le constate
par soi-même.
Je lui ferai
une aide
semblable à lui.
donc l'aide
Donc,
l'origine,
c'est la partie
vraiment complémentaire.
C'est quelque chose
qui va,
qui mutuellement
vont se compléter.
L'éternel Dieu
forma de la terre
tous les animaux
des champs
et tous les oiseaux
du ciel
et les fit venir
vers l'homme
pour voir comment
il l'appellerait
et afin que tout
être vivant
portât les noms
qui lui donnerait
l'homme.
Donc,
c'est intéressant.
On ne croit pas
dans la macroévolution
mais nous savons
très bien
qu'il y a
toute une variété
d'une même espèce
qui peut se développer
par des microévolutions.
On peut dire
comme ça,
pas de changement
d'espèce
mais variété.
Donc,
selon les calculs
des certains scientifiques,
dans trois heures,
Adam serait capable
de nommer
toutes les espèces
d'animaux
qu'il aurait pu
faire face
avec sa capacité
de raisonner
selon Dieu,
de répondre
aux informations
qu'il reçoit
en observant
les mondes
que Dieu a programmés
pour lui
et qu'il a programmés
l'homme
pour avoir
cette capacité
de comprendre
les choses
que Dieu fait.
Et donc,
les animaux
des chiens
mais pour l'homme
il les trouva
point d'aide
semblable à lui.
Alors,
l'homme a eu
la capacité
quand même
d'identifier
les sexes
complémentaires
dans tous les animaux
mais quelque chose
qui lui manquait.
Donc,
l'éternel,
Dieu fit tomber
en profond sommeil
sur l'homme
qui s'endormit.
Donc,
anesthésie générale.
Il prit
une de ses côtes
donc la côte
c'est l'une des parties
du corps humain
si vous voulez étudier
sur les clones
c'est l'une des parties
du corps humain
qui a les plus
de cellules couches
et c'est
la partie
souche, pardon,
la plus appropriée
pour produire.
C'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment les sexes
masculins
ont dû être créés
d'abord
car c'est les x, y
c'est ça ?
Comment ça vous dites ?
Y
et donc
la femme x, x
l'homme x, y
et heureusement
Dieu
dans sa sagesse
n'a pas doublé
les x
sinon ça serait
Adam et Yves
mais heureusement
c'était Adam
et Ève.
C'était l'intentionnalité
des dieux
et l'homme
avait cette capacité
de produire
Dieu avait cette capacité
à partir de l'homme
de produire la femme
mais l'inverse
ne serait pas possible
et là c'est intéressant
une aide semblable à lui
alors l'Éternel
fit tomber
en profond sommeil
et renferma
la chair à sa place
ou dans l'original
c'est comme si
Dieu avait
utilisé
de la chair
pour fermer la place
comme on fait
dans certaines chirurgies
aujourd'hui
pour faire osage
d'une partie
pour que ça soit
parfaitement
restauré.
L'Éternel Dieu
forma une femme
de la côte
qu'il avait prise
de l'homme
et il l'amena
vers l'homme
et l'homme
donc ici c'est très important
avant la chute
il n'y a pas
de coupabilisation
envers l'autre
ici nous sommes
devant
les premiers poèmes
qu'on va trouver
dans la Bible
et l'homme dit
voici cette fois
celle qui est
haut de mes os
chair de ma chair
donc reconnaissance
d'être quelque chose
qui va les compléter
de cette intégrité
une seule chair
l'humanité
et la capacité
pleine
de l'humanité
par ces couples
d'aboutir
à la représentation
de l'image
de Dieu
une seule chair
on va dire
Dieu
une seule substance
subsistant
trois personnes
pluralité de personnes
unité
et ici nous voyons
cette gloire
de Dieu
voici
cette fois celle
qui est haut de mes os
et chair de ma chair
on l'appellera
femme
qui à la base
les mots
vont être presque
donc on a
Adam
qui veut dire
non
plutôt
homme
et c'est comme
si on disait
Oma
quelque part
ou Ome
je ne sais pas
c'est la réalité
tout simplement
d'échanger
une petite particule
et donc c'était
vraiment
pour mettre en emphase
la majorité
des similarités
avec la distinction
fondamentale
entre les sexes
et c'est pourquoi
l'homme quittera
son père et sa mère
s'attachera à sa femme
et ils deviendront
une seule chair
donc les mariages
Jésus a interprété
et a cité
ces passages
comme littéral
comme historique
pour donner
la base universelle
du mariage
hétérosexuel
d'une alliance
incassable
pour toute la vie
l'homme
et sa femme
étaient tous
deux nus
et ils avaient
point d'hente
parfaitement
c'est complémentant
aucune honte
aucune distorsion
sexuelle
aucune immoralité
aucune corruption
sexuelle
mais parfaitement
en harmonie
ensuite
la Bible va décrire
comment
nous passons
au prochain état
donc l'image
pervertie
les péchés
défiguraient
l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
bien que l'homme
conserve encore
une image
imparfaite
des dieux
donc comment
la chute a eu lieu
c'est très important
de reconnaître
et de remarquer
dans la Bible
que la chute
a eu lieu
à partir du moment
où l'homme
il a marché
contrairement
à l'image
des dieux
qu'il devrait porter
il devrait représenter
Dieu
pour protéger
les jardins
pour agir
en tant qu'homme
et empêcher
par exemple
que la femme
prenne la direction
et qu'elle avance
il a reçu d'abord
la responsabilité
de leadership
il a reçu
la parole
de Dieu
qu'il a interdit
de manger
les fruits
et l'homme
au lieu
ayant toute cette
rédivité
d'ailleurs
c'est Dieu
qui va appeler
d'abord
l'homme
lorsqu'ils ont tombé
même si
celle qui a initié
les péchés
c'était la femme
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
Dieu va appeler
l'homme
pour qu'il soit
rédivable
et donc ici
c'est très important
à plusieurs égards
l'homme va agir
contrairement
à la volonté
de Dieu
contrairement
à la parole
révélée de Dieu
à l'autorité
suprême
de Dieu
contrairement
au mandat
de fonctionner
comme Dieu
pour protéger
et pour cultiver
et donc
les serpents
étaient plus rusés
Genèse 3
de tous les animaux
du champ
que l'éternel
avait fait
il dit à la femme
Dieu
a-t-il réellement dit
donc il a mis en question
la parole de Dieu
vous ne mangerez pas
en distorsant
en portant des mensonges
car Dieu n'a pas dit
de ne pas manger
de tous les arbres
il a juste
de ne pas manger
d'un seul arbre
et la femme a répondu
au serpent
verset 2
nous mangeons
du fruit
des arbres du jardin
mais quant au fruit
de l'arbre
qui est au milieu
du jardin
Dieu a dit
vous n'en mangerez point
et vous
n'y toucherez point
des peurs
que vous n'y mourriez
alors le serpent dit
à la femme
vous ne mourrez point
mais Dieu sait
que les jours
où vous en mangerez
vos yeux s'ouvriront
et que vous serez
comme des dieux
connaissant
les biens
et les mals
et donc c'est intéressant
ils étaient déjà
l'image des dieux
ils étaient conscients
d'avoir été créé
l'image des dieux
mais il y a une tentation
comme s'il y avait
plusieurs dieux
possiblement
comme si Satan
pourrait représenter
l'un de ses dieux
et en suggérant
que la femme
ne soit pas
qu'une image
des dieux
mais qu'elle soit
l'autorité suprême
Dieu lui-même
et la femme
vit que l'arbre
était bon à manger
agréable à la vue
et qu'il était précieux
pour ouvrir
l'intelligence
donc intéressant
elle a donné
plus d'essence
à ses parties
les moins nobles
les plus charnelles
les plus animales
et les plus on s'éloigne
de la noblesse
de l'image des dieux
les plus l'être humain
se porte comme un animal
et donc en cherchant
une intelligence corrompue
elle finit
pour commettre
quelque chose
complètement non raisonnable
attirée
et laissée
laissant dominer
par les parties
les moins nobles
même si
ces choses
n'étaient pas corrompues
avant
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer aussi
que la femme
elle n'a pas été
soumise
à la parole
qu'elle avait reçue
de l'homme
la parole
qu'elle a reçue
des dieux
à travers l'homme
et l'homme
qui était
pendant tout ce temps
à côté de la femme
et qui n'a rien fait
pour empêcher
pour exercer sa protection
ou son leadership
et donc les yeux
des l'un
et des l'autre
s'ouvrirent
pardon
la femme vit
qu'elle avait été bon
donc elle en mangea
elle donna aussi
à son mari
qui était auprès d'elle
et il en a mangé
les yeux
des l'un
et des l'autre
s'ouvrirent
ils connurent
qu'ils étaient nus
et donc là
on commence à voir
l'impact
sur tous les aspects
et la fragmentation
de l'homme
tout était harmonique
il n'y avait pas
des désirs désordonnés
des désirs du corps
etc
il n'y avait pas
d'honte
des corruptions
tout était parfait
à partir de là
il y a toute cette
fragmentation
donc ils ont vu
qu'ils étaient nus
donc la conscience
la coupabilité
alors ils entendirent
la voix des dieux
qui parcouraient
les jardins
vers les soirs
et l'homme
et sa femme
s'est cachèrent
loin de la face
éternelle
donc qu'est-ce que
je vous ai dit
être image des dieux
commence avec
être devant dieux
être devant la face
des dieux
quelle est la réaction
maintenant
s'enfuir de la face
de l'éternel
envers les milieux
des arbres du jardin
c'est fou
l'homme qui ressortait
d'entre toute la création
dont les arbres
étaient infiniment
secondaires
par rapport
à eux
qui devraient éclater
maintenant cherche
à se cacher des dieux
par des choses
beaucoup infiniment inférieures
à eux-mêmes
donc les conséquences
ce n'était pas
la suppression complète
mais
tous les aspects
ont été corrompus
et l'impact
s'est porté
envers
tous les airs
de ce qui devrait
fonctionner
en tant qu'image des dieux
donc je n'ai pas le temps
de traverser
tous les détails du texte
donc on peut relire
les versets 8
à 19
du chapitre 3
mais vous allez remarquer
les conséquences
du péché
donc à nouveau
agir contrairement
à l'image des dieux
nous a conduit
au péché
et c'était aussi
une conséquence
du péché
donc l'homme
qui devrait travailler
qui était bon
le travail
maintenant va transpirer
et va lutter
la création
qui nous servait
volontairement
et contente
va agir contrairement
à nous
et la femme
qui avait reçu
cette tâche privilégiée
de multiplier
maintenant souffrira
des douleurs
et il y a une phrase
qui va déterminer
ce que nous sommes
en train de vivre
dans les dernières générations
où
Dieu va dire
à la femme
donc Dieu a dit
à la fin verset 16
j'augmenterai
la souffrance
de tes grossesses
tu enfanteras
avec douleur
et tes désirs
se porteront
vers ton mari
mais il te dominera
et c'est là
on voit l'inversion
de ce qu'était
la complémentarité
la femme
qui était censée
être l'aide
de l'homme
sous la même mission
ayant dans la même direction
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer ici
elle aura
un désir
pour la position
d'autorité
du mari
et quelle sera
la réaction
du mari
ou quelle sera
la tendance
du mari
en dépendant
de l'action
ou réaction
de la femme
c'est de dominer
la femme
donc les pages
de l'histoire
vont marquer
l'homme
qui va dominer
pour la plupart
des temps
de manière tyrannique
de manière abusive
et comme réaction
donc les femmes
qui vont être montrées
aussi au long de l'histoire
à plusieurs reprises
en manipulant
elles ne vont pas
toujours chercher
à se mettre
dans la position
de leadership
par cette réclamation
d'autorité
ou d'égalité
qu'on voit aujourd'hui
mais pendant
la plupart des temps
elle va chercher
à manipuler
les circonstances
de manière cynique
dissimulée
pour contrôler
les choses
parfois même
avec une voix
à velouté
une voix douce
comme la femme
par exemple
des sansans
et donc là
on voit
de manière très claire
dans les pages
donc la femme
d'Hérode
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
nous devons tous
être très attentifs
car
dans l'ADN
corrompu
de l'être humain
dans la chair
dans les restes
il y aura
cette indisposition
à agir
envers l'image
de Dieu en nous
et l'homme
parfois va réagir
avec négligence
et lâcheté
comme les hommes
qui aujourd'hui
sont en train
de permettre
que les femmes
occupent les positions
des pasteurs
dans les églises
et des fois
donc cette lâcheté
est très intéressante
car si la femme
veut tout faire
ils ne vont rien faire
mais de l'autre côté
parfois
ils sont très abusifs
et de l'autre côté
c'est la même chose
la femme parfois
va manipuler
de manière
dissimulée
et plus récemment
pour la première fois
dans l'histoire
cette renversion
des rôles
nous sommes devant
la génération
où les femmes
sont les plus masculinisées
et les hommes
les plus féminisés
à cause d'un manque
de repères
dans l'ordre des choses
et donc ici
c'est très important
pour nous
de comprendre
que
renouveler l'image
des gens en nous
passe par
être très diligent
et intentionnel
à restaurer
l'image des dieux
en moi
en tant qu'homme
en tant que père
en tant que mari
l'image des dieux
chez la femme
en tant que femme
en tant qu'aide
en tant qu'épouse
en tant qu'mère
et donc
c'est très important
de nous rappeler
que cette difficulté
à accepter la vérité
et l'ordre des dieux
aujourd'hui
est aussi une conséquence
de la chute
mais l'image des dieux
continue malgré la chute
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que malgré
toute la promotion
et toutes
les essais
de légiférer
sur
la renversion
de l'ordre
créé par Dieu
c'est intéressant
comment
plus tôt
ou plus tard
on va voir
comment les mouvements
extrêmes
vont ressortir
et vont chercher
l'opposé
les femmes
qui vont réclamer
dans nos jours
où sont les hommes
etc
et la mise en question
de toute cette promotion
même si ça reste
encore délicat
dans nos jours
mais on voit
quand même
toujours
que même si la chair
joue
contrairement
à l'image
des dieux en nous
les restes
c'est l'image
de Dieu
nous pousse
aussi
par les demandes
les plus profondes
à chercher
à vivre
un peu
de ces réalités
et donc
la Bible nous dit
de manière très claire
que l'image
elle reste
chez l'homme
même après la chute
Genèse chapitre 5
voici
les livres
de la postérité
d'Adam
là c'est après la chute
les jours où Dieu
créa l'homme
il est fille
à la rassemblance
des dieux
il créa l'homme
et la femme
et les bénis
il leur donna
les noms
d'hommes
lorsqu'il fut créé
Adam vécu 130 ans
et il engendra un fils
à sa rassemblance
selon son image
et il l'appela
Seth
donc ici
on sait très bien
c'est en bon espoir
Seth
la nouvelle lignée
qui représente
les enfants des dieux
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
nous sommes déjà
après la chute
et les privilèges
glorieux et énormes
d'enfanter
l'image des dieux
de toutes les oeuvres
qu'on puisse faire
en tant qu'image des dieux
récréer les choses
organiser les choses
il n'y a aucune chose
qui soit si glorieuse
qui est la capacité
de reproduire
l'image des dieux
donc ça c'est tout simplement
glorieux
malgré la chute
et les langages ici
il est ancré
sur la notion
de l'image des dieux
d'ailleurs
ces privilèges
je ne sais pas
si vous avez déjà eu
ces moments
cette épiphanie
moi c'est passé déjà
avec moi plusieurs reprises
mais d'observer un peu
les éléments de la nature
les animaux
et de se dire
ma chair parfois
elle en vit un chiant
qui dort toute la journée
mais quand on réfléchit
vraiment
et là c'est vraiment
la chair qui est en train
de s'afficher
c'est la chair
mais quand on réfléchit
bien
qu'on se dit
mais quelle chose
incroyable
par les choix
de dieux
par une raison
qui m'échappe
par son amour
sa grâce
il a décidé
que moi
je ne serais pas
un chiant
je serais son image
ça devrait nous étonner
quel privilège
avoir été créé
à l'image des dieux
et donc c'est
celui qui répandra
les seins
de l'homme
par l'homme
son sang
sera répandu
car l'homme
a été fait
à l'image des dieux
donc les potentiels
que l'homme
possède encore
d'être image des dieux
et les statuts
que l'homme possède
qui n'est pas
passible
de se perdre
c'est quelque chose
sur laquelle
se base
les seuls arguments
métaphysiques
pour justifier
la sainteté
de la vie humaine
pour parler
des droits
des hommes
et donc là
c'est après la chute
et ça continue
donc l'homme
est profondément
corrompu
à la racine
ça porte des corruptions
dans tous les airs
de sa vie
c'est comme
Lloyd-Jones disait
les ruines
d'un château
qui un jour
a été glorieux
on peut identifier
qu'il y a un château
et malheureusement
nous voyons plutôt
les aspects
défigurés
et obscurcis
de l'image des dieux
comme dit Calvin
après la chute
l'image des dieux
reste en nous
mais elle est comme
défigurée
obscurcie
ce n'est pas
qu'elle a disparu
complètement
mais elle a été
gravement altérée
par les péchés
donc ça fait
que dans la condition
actuelle
on ne puisse pas
nier que l'être humain
n'est pas
de la raisonnabilité
mais ça nous étonne
qu'il utilise
sa raisonnabilité
pour raisonner
contre Dieu
par exemple
il y a un livre
où Schaeffer
il va parler
d'un film
car on sait
que c'est surtout
par les arts
que la philosophie
essaie de rendre
les choses relatives
et tout ça
et il y avait
un film en français
qui était appelé
Pierre les Fous
et la théorie
relativiste
de son auteur
c'était de défendre
les relativismes
l'existentialisme
les nihilismes
les manques d'essence
les durs
c'est que Pierre les Fous
pour montrer
qu'il ne sortirait pas
par la porte
car tout est relative
il devrait quand même
sortir par la fenêtre
il ne pouvait pas
traverser les murs
et donc ils sont en train
d'utiliser
leur raisonnement
qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à échapper
les règles
de la raison
pour chercher
à nous convaincre
que les choses
n'ont pas de raison
ou ceux qui veulent
nous convaincre
que la communication
n'est pas possible
dans nos jours
qu'on doit mettre
en question
l'assurance
d'avoir la capacité
de nous communiquer
la folie
c'est qu'ils utilisent
beaucoup des mots
et des paroles
et des livres
qui doivent avoir
du sens
pour pouvoir nous convaincre
que les choses
n'ont pas de sens
et donc aujourd'hui
la discussion folle
de l'identité
des genres
etc
c'est complètement
à côté de la plaque
par rapport
à l'usage
qu'ils font
eux-mêmes
des beaucoup
des raisonnements
qui vont jouer
à la fin des comptes
contrairement
à toute cette folie
et donc la réalité
c'est que l'être humain
est en train
de agir
contrairement
à la raison
mais en utilisant
la raison elle-même
contre la piété
contre la sainteté
mais elle n'arrive pas
à supprimer complètement
l'image des dieux
en elle
et elle reste
insatisfaite
car c'est que Dieu
qui peut remplir
donc
le troisième état
donc la chute
l'image des dieux
à la chute
et ensuite
les privilèges
de la régénération
de l'image des dieux
en nous
c'est très intéressant
car l'écrit
ce nous est présenté
par plusieurs textes
je vais vous citer
vous pouvez lire après
mais
Romain chapitre 5
nous parle
de l'ancien Adam
ou les premiers Adam
et les nouveaux Adam
qui est venu
apporter la restauration
donc là
c'est l'image des dieux
exacte
en Christ
qui vient
pour opérer
la rédemption
pour rénover
l'image des dieux
en nous
donc le langage
de l'image des dieux
est très présent
quand Christ
nous est présenté
deuxième Corinthiens 5
va nous dire
verset 16 et 17
ainsi
dès maintenant
nous ne connaissons
personne par la chair
ou selon la chair
et si nous avons connu
Christ selon la chair
maintenant nous ne les connaissons
plus de cette manière
si quelqu'un est en Christ
il est une nouvelle créature
les choses anciennes
sont passées
voici toutes choses
sont devenues nouvelles
donc c'est carrément
une nouvelle création
en Christ
voilà pourquoi
il est la tête
nous sommes les corps
mais c'est à l'image du Christ
que nous trouvons
la nouvelle création
nous voyons
la même chose
lorsque l'Écrit
nous est présenté
par Hébreu
chapitre 1
après avoir autrefois
à plusieurs reprises
et plusieurs manières
parlé à nos pères
par les prophètes
Dieu dans ces derniers temps
nous a parlé
par les fils
qu'il a établi
héritier de toutes choses
par lesquels
il a aussi créé
le monde
et qui étend
les reflets de sa gloire
l'emprunte de sa personne
et soutenant toutes choses
par sa parole puissante
a fait la purification
des péchés
c'est ainsi à la douleur
de la majesté divine
dans les lieux très hauts
devenu d'autant supérieur
aux anges
qu'il a hérité
d'un nom plus excellent
que le leur
en tant que Dieu
Jésus a toujours été
plus élevé que les anges
mais en tant qu'être humain
pour la première fois
il va rentrer dans les ciels
et occuper une position
supérieure
à celle des anges
donc c'est très intéressant
de considérer
comment notre état
en Christ
après la régénération
est un état supérieur
à celui même des anges
et c'est surtout important
pour nous considérer
que la restauration
de l'image des gens
en nous
ne pourrait pas être possible
si Christ
ne viendrait pas
pour être
quelque part
véritablement homme
voilà pourquoi Galate 4
nous dit
né d'une femme
est né sous la loi
pour accomplir
la promesse à Ève
donc on va déjà
dans les contextes
de la chute
au moment où
à l'aidant même
Dieu était en train
de nous montrer clairement
que la chute a eu lieu
car on a agi
contrairement à l'image
de Dieu
la conséquence
de la chute
était
de défigurer davantage
l'image des gens
en nous
mais dès la création
encore
dès la chute
à ce moment encore
en Genèse chapitre 3
nous voyons
comment Dieu
va lui-même promettre
que ça sera
un descendant
de l'image
de Dieu
qui viendra
et qui écrasera
la tête du serpent
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui va sacrifier
ces animaux
pour couvrir
non des plantes
mais des peaux
Adam et Ève
et c'est Dieu lui-même
qui va empêcher
qu'il mange
les fruits
de la vie
pour qu'il ne rende pas
leur condition
corrompue éternelle
et qu'il les chasse
du jardin
pour empêcher
qu'il mange
mais en mettant
des chérubans
qui représentent
l'humanité glorifiée
et donc
là quelque part
c'est intéressant
car Dieu lui-même
va prénoncer
et proclamer
l'évangile
et
déjà Adam
expérimente
une régénération
de son image
de Dieu
car il va changer
le nom
de sa femme
Ève
qui s'appelait
tout simplement
femme
il va la nommer
maintenant
mère
Ève
qui veut dire mère
pour démontrer
sa foi
dans la promesse
de Dieu
et son espoir
et la traiter
à nouveau
comme il faut
avec amour
avec dignité
et donc
c'est important
de quelle manière
Adam accomplit
ses modèles
spirituels
en changeant
le nom
des mères
de Ève
pardon
des femmes
à Ève
dans ces cadres
et donc
Exode
chapitre 20
Dieu nous donne
les dix commandements
pour qu'on se rappelle
que l'image
des dieux
est liée
aux dix commandements
on n'a pas le temps
mais l'image
des dieux
est fondée
sur les dix commandements
quelque part
où les dix commandements
décrivent l'image
des dieux
la relation avec Dieu
la relation avec les hommes
la relation avec les mondes
les animaux
etc
tout cela sera retrouvé
à partir
des dix commandements
ensuite
donc notre vie
sera marquée
par toutes ces exhortations
qui nous recevons
nous les chrétiens
à renouveler
l'image des dieux
en nous
comme on a lu
en Colossians
n'aimentez pas
les uns aux autres
vous étant
dépuyés
du vieil homme
et de ses œuvres
et ayant revêtu
l'homme nouveau
qui se renouvelle
dans la connaissance
selon l'image
de celui
qu'il a créé
et donc
il n'y a ni grec
ni juif
ni circoncis
ni en circoncis
mais Christ
en tout
et en tous
et donc
l'appel biblique
suprême
se trouve
en deuxième
Corinthien 3
pour tous les croyants
donc
quelle est
la restauration
de l'image
des dieux
en nous
c'est la restauration
de notre capacité
de vivre
tel qu'est Christ
tel qu'image
des dieux
et donc
la responsabilité
la rédivabilité
nous allons rendre compte
si nous sommes
en train
ou non
de restaurer
l'image des dieux
en nous
et de fonctionner
comme représentant des dieux
dans toutes les relations
qu'on a
dans nos vies
et donc ici
jusqu'à ces jours
quand on lit Moïse
un voile
est jeté
sur leur cœur
mais lorsque les cœurs
se convertissent au Seigneur
le voile est ôté
or le Seigneur
c'est l'Esprit
et là où est l'Esprit
du Seigneur
là est la liberté
nous tous
qui
les visages découverts
contemplons
comme dans un miroir
la gloire du Seigneur
nous sommes transformés
en la même image
des gloires
en gloire
comme par le Seigneur
l'Esprit
donc dans la dépendance
du Saint-Esprit
notre objectif
en tant que chrétien
c'est de contempler Christ
dans les pages
des Écritures
et l'observer
dans toutes les esphères
de la vie
et apprendre
avec ses enseignements
la manière
dont il a traité
les femmes
c'est qu'il a attendu
des services
des femmes
il a été servi
il a mis en évidence
plusieurs femmes
mais il n'a jamais
mis les femmes
dans une position
d'évidence dangereuse
il aurait pu
en situer
des apostrices
je ne sais pas
mais la réalité
c'est qu'il les a protégés
il a reçu
leur service
de manière très féminine
mais il n'a jamais
ponté une femme
pour une position
de leadership
et donc la réalité
c'est que quand on voit
l'enseignement d'épaule
par rapport à la relation
du Christ
avec l'Église
nous devons apprendre
par là
à renouveler l'image
des gens en nous
en fonctionnant
comme homme
comme femme
comme employeur
et comme employé
et à tous égards
fonctionner
comme enfant
ou comme parent
comme image de Dieu
et donc là
on a
les derniers états
les quatrièmes états
c'est l'image perfectionnée
lorsque Christ viendra
l'image de Dieu
sera pleinement restaurée
dans les croyants
donc voilà pourquoi
c'est intéressant
la certitude
elle est tellement pleine
que tous les chrétiens
finiront dans cet état
de gloire
et c'est une perte
de temps
de ne pas s'habituer
aux choses dans nous
à notre vraie identité
dans le futur
à ne pas être
ce qui nous serons
ce qui nous sommes déjà
avec notre vie
cachée en Christ
d'être les plus authentiques
qui est possible
n'est pas d'être authentiques
vis-à-vis à nos désirs pécheurs
car plusieurs fois
il y a certains chrétiens
tièdes
qui vont dire
ça ne serait pas
honnête de ma part
de ne pas céder
à cette tentation
car j'essaierais
en train d'être
d'agir contrairement
à mes désirs
et la réalité
c'est que la chair
a ses désirs
mais notre désir
le plus profond
du vrai chrétien
c'est d'être
tel qu'est Christ
et donc
c'est hypocrite
de ne pas commencer
à être tel
qui nous serons
tel qui nous sommes
véritablement
tel qui nous serons
inévitablement
voilà pourquoi
Jean-Édouard
il disait dans ses résolutions
qu'il a décidé
il a résolu
de vivre
d'une telle manière
il allait concentrer
tous ses efforts
pour vivre d'une telle manière
qu'il lui-même
considérerait
lorsqu'il serait
dans la gloire glorifiée
avoir été
la meilleure manière
de vivre
aujourd'hui
vous comprenez ?
il s'est projeté
en tant qu'il glorifié
à côté des dieux
devant Christ
et il a regardé
sa vie en arrière
en se demandant
à soi-même
dans la gloire
est-ce que je suis
en train de vivre
aujourd'hui
tel que je devrais vivre ?
Est-ce que je suis
en train d'agir
intentionnellement
pour contempler
les visages du Christ
anticiper
la vision béatifique
car quand ce jour
arrivera
la révélation
du fils des dieux
roman 8 nous dit
toute la création
attend ce jour-là
car la création
elle-même
sortira
de son esclavage
elle est otage
de nos péchés
aujourd'hui
réduite à la vanité
et elle sera restaurée
lorsqu'elle contemplera
la révélation
pleine des enfants
des dieux
l'abbé nous dit
que lorsqu'il crie
il reviendra
il va ressusciter
son peuple
et il va glorifier
nous sommes en train
de s'aimer
avec une chair
une maison corruptible
et on reviendra
avec une chair
incorruptible
et dans ces moments
des rencontres
c'est qu'ils seront
vivants
rencontreront
Christ dans les airs
et seront glorifiés
et donc
c'est ça
qu'on devrait
anticiper
on a plein
des versets bibliques
qui nous parlent
de cette assemblée
des premiers-nés
inscrits dans les cieux
et qu'ils nous brilleront
comme la splendeur
du ciel
et qu'ils nous seront glorifiés
conformément à son image
1 Corinthiens 15-42
pour finir
ainsi